j'arrive sur mime pour vous proposer
quelque chose de différent prolongé
l'expérience avec la Snake Army toutes
les semaines des échanges du partage des
avant-première des places à gagner des
accès backstage bref ici sur mime je
suis ici pour vous proposer une
expérience autour de ma musique de mon
quotidien d'artiste comme je l'ai jamais
fait autre part c'est assez simple pour
moi mime c'est le nexting pendant son
bon compte sur la plateforme je vais
aussi ouvrir la voie aux autres artistes
au Créateur du monde entier
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez avoir accès à tous ces
contenus abonnez-vous à mon compte
sauf qu'en réalité
99% c'est pas ça hyper dangereux
sponsorise et investissent dans une
plateforme comme mime qui qu'on le
veuille ou non dans l'inconscient
collective c'est effectivement une
plateforme on paye des photos dénudées
clairement on prend des abonnements pour
voir des photos dénudées d'homme ou de
femmes et en plus je crois qu'il milite
dans ses clips pour ne pas avoir
justement une donnée une image des
gardons de la femme de ne pas avoir de
fit trop sexy donc il a dû prendre
évidemment un énorme chien mais alors
c'est pas forcément dégradant parce que
c'est un choix de la personne
aujourd'hui
le prix le plus bas et tu reverse une
petite partie c'est ça les associations
de faire des vidéos toute la journée
pour gonfler leur followers pour après
vendre des produits etc là il y a pas de
pub dessus voilà tu t'abonnes tu
t'abonnes pas tu mets des contenus
tu fais des likes ils ont mis le
problème c'est que c'est à la limite de
la pornographie c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
gens arrondissent leur foin de moi voir
gagne beaucoup d'argent en vendant des
photos de nu en oubliant que c'est des
traces qui restent plus tard et c'est un
moyen déplorable de gagner de l'argent
aujourd'hui je suis désolé et le Hard
tous les cas ça marche ça marche très
bien ça marche c'est comme la
pornographie et la prostitution ça
marche
de digeste qui va le faire d'autre chose
ça devient un peu mais c'est pour
redorer l'image
d'accord
j'ai un scoop sur mime si ça vous
intéresse non pas du tout bonne
révélation
de la table
quelqu'un au milieu de la table
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est bon on va on va changer
de sujet être sûr parce que oui
qui est sur mime vous le saviez oh là là
ça y est c'est ma mère la femme non mon
père non
à mes enfants
ma femme non la fiancée d'un de vos
enfants
et oui vous savez qui ou pas je me doute
un peu là je alors je dis ça je l'aime
beaucoup c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup adixia
[Rires]
merci beaucoup